hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds
I've become a multi multi-millionaire by
investing in property I don't know much
about lots of things but I do know a lot
when it comes to property money finance
debt mortgages I meet a lot of people
that have no choice they have to use
mortgages they have to borrow other
people's money to buy property why
because they have none and what I find
really interesting is recently I've been
working with high net worth individuals
I've been working for celebrities I've
been working with overseas investors
that have got millions of pounds to
invest and they keep saying the same
thing I want to invest cash just because
I don't want to die with debt you've got
it completely wrong and in this video
I'm gonna be explaining why you've got
it wrong and why you should be using
mortgages even if you don't need to use
mortgages even if you're a Multi multi
multi-millionaire Donald Trump you might
not like the guy you might think he's a
complete jerk but you can't deny he's
very very wealthy Multi multi multi
billionaire guess what he is one of the
most high net worth individuals as well
as high net worth individuals he has got
a lot of debt so don't think debt and
legacy or separate don't think debt and
being a billionaire separate they're
completely not we're gonna take two
scenarios scenario number one is you're
30 years old you've got a million pounds
to invest congratulations you've
obviously worked really hard or you've
done something great you've got a
million pounds you want to invest it
without mortgages and then the other
case that is that you're going to invest
it and you're gonna utilize mortgages
and let's see what happens at the end of
both of their lives assuming that they
die young and they die at 60 years old
person number one is they use the 1
million pounds they buy a house worth a
million pounds they buy it for a million
pounds they've got a ten percent rental
yield and they're renting the property
out for 100,000 pounds per year now of
course there's going to be some expenses
on that hundred thousand pounds each
year but at least you don't have to pay
more with interest payments though right
your plan is you're just going to rent
this property out get a nice little
income off of it and then in time wait
for it to go up in value to leave a
legacy for your children now if you're
buying in the UK in Britain it's pretty
safe to say that the property is going
to go up in time because we're in a very
small island there's a massive shortage
of houses there's an overpopulation of
people and historically property prices
in Britain tend to double in value I
and every ten years so you buy this
property for cash thirty years old and
then in ten years it's worth two million
pounds fantastic and then let's say you
now forty years old and you wait another
ten years and nothing happens to the
property it but say it's pretty static
there's some problems going on
we have World War three who knows what
happens and then at 50 years old in
doubles again and it goes from two
million to four million
very very likely and then you die and
you leave your children a property worth
four million pounds with no mortgage
your net worth is four million pounds
and it's producing your rent the rent
would have probably gone up at least in
line with inflation but let's just for
argument's sake say the rent is still
one hundred thousand pounds that is
option number one option number two is
that either the exact same you do the
exact same investment but you use
mortgage instead so in this option
instead of buying one house and paying 1
million pounds you buy four houses that
are each worth 1 million pounds each and
you put a deposit of 250,000 pounds down
on each property meaning that you've now
got 4 mortgages and each mortgage is 750
thousand pounds you are officially in
debt although you're in debt your net
worth
currently at 30 years old is exactly the
same you are still worth 1 million
pounds just because you have debt
doesn't mean your net worth is any less
it also doesn't mean that your net worth
is any more only for houses doesn't make
you worth any more than owning one house
because of the mortgages so you're kind
of in the same situation now cash flow
we'll look at shortly but let's just
look at what happens when you die at 60
years old assuming that you have all of
this debt well each property will be
will go up in value like the other one
did you've now got four houses that are
each worth four million pounds which
means your total portfolio is now worth
16 million pounds that's the power of
leverage that's the power of debt but of
course you've now got all of these
mortgages and you've left your kids with
all of this debt so what happens well
what happens is the debt is just - off
of the total portfolio value or how much
is the debt the debt hasn't gone up
anymore the debt is 750 times 4
your total debt is three million pounds
so your net worth
instead of being four million pounds is
now 16 million pounds minus 3 million
pounds so your net worth is in this case
13 million pounds because you used debt
you now are more than three times as
rich as the person who didn't utilize
debt
so it just illogically makes sense
instead of buying one house for cash to
buy four houses utilize that you're
gonna be a lot lot richer doing that
let's also look at cash flow one of the
reasons people don't want to use
mortgages is because they say they don't
want to have to pay the interest
payments you are going to be paying
interest payments of course let's look
at interest only which I suggest I do
not suggest trying to pay the mortgages
off at all any money that you would
usually typically want to pay the
mortgages off you should be using to buy
more houses and putting more deposits
down leave originally more money getting
more debt and also growing your network
you've got four houses each are
producing a gross annual rent of 100,000
pounds a year which is 10% yield which
is very very reasonable so of that
100,000 pounds how much are you gonna
have to be paying on the interest
payments well right now interest
payments were around about 3% you can
fix interest payments for quite a long
time but let's be conservative and let's
say that the interest payments are five
percent well five percent of seven
hundred and fifty thousand pounds which
is the debt on one house is thirty seven
and a half thousand pounds you're not
just gonna have to pay thirty seven and
a half thousand pounds per annum once
you have to pay that much property so
thirty seven and a half thousand pounds
for properties means that you're gonna
have to pay a one hundred and fifty
thousand pounds per year just on
mortgage interest payments isn't that
dead money why would you want to pay a
one hundred and fifty thousand pounds a
year on interest payments because the
mortgages have meant that you cannot
have four properties which means instead
of having a rent roll of one hundred
thousand pounds a year you've got a rent
roll of four hundred thousand pounds a
year so that one hundred and fifty
thousand pounds is not going to be paid
by you it's gonna be paid by your
tenants meaning that instead of making
one hundred thousand pounds a year
roll you're making 250,000 pounds a year
cash flow from the property which means
not only have you got a portfolio and
your net worth is more than three times
as much but your cash flow each year is
also two and a half times as much so in
every which possible way an angle you
look at this you are going to be richer
you're gonna leave the better legacy for
your kids and you're gonna be much more
likely to become a billionaire by using
debt so my conclusion is if you have the
money and you're fortunate enough to buy
properties for cash
don't buy properties for cash still use
mortgages still get into debt just make
sure you bind the right kind of houses
that are giving you the maximum cash
flow as possible you fix the interest
payments as long as they can you risk
assess everything and always have a plan
if you're a celebrity or if you are a
business person you've got millions of
pounds in the bank and you want to chat
and you want some help or you want some
advice then please get in touch with the
team I'd love to hear from you if you
like the youtube channel please don't
forget to subscribe
smash that like button I did a whole
video good debt bad do whatever you've
got right here also if you want to come
on down to the crash course if you want
to meet me one on one very very
expensive if you want me to come and
speaker your event it's very very
expensive crash course learn everything
for free you can do that right here I
definitely get booked on too late young
men and also subscribe right over here
thanks so much I'll see you next time
[Music]